what's going on everyone i'm richard
this is richard on data
i just hit 5 000 subscribers and i have
each and every one of you all to thank
for that
so keep watching this video and i'm
going to talk about why i started this
channel in the first place
and then where it's going in the year
2021
[Music]
so i started this channel in november of
last year
meaning i've been doing this for just
over a year at this point
now that i've hit 5000 subscribers to
tell you the truth
i couldn't think of anything too special
for this occasion
but i do think that it presents a good
opportunity both for the new people and
for the people who've been around for a
longer time
i'm going to talk about what motivated
me to start a youtube channel in the
first place
and then i have big plans for the year
2021 so i do want to talk about those as
well
before i do any of that hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already hit the notification bell so
that youtube notifies you whenever i
upload a video
and then lastly if you guys would be
willing to support me over on patreon
i'll have a link to that in the
description of the video it's massively
appreciated
alright so why did i start the channel
well
prior to starting it i had had the
desire to embark on some kind of
entrepreneurial endeavor for quite some
time
there's a couple reasons for that first
and foremost is i think
us humans do have it embedded in our dna
to want to create things
it's way too easy to get sucked into the
monotony of day after day
consuming social media consuming one
episode after another of netflix
and i really do think these sorts of
behaviors are causing my generation the
millennials
to be a little bit more depressed and
anxious than previous generations were
if we haven't put our mark on the
universe in some capacity
there's just this sort of void inside of
us it's a fact that many of us use
youtube
every single day to learn how to do new
things
and if nobody out there took the time to
actually create that content
we would all be a lot worse off for that
so that's the first thing the second
reason is
youtube is basically the definition of a
passive income model
so i got to be honest with all of you
guys i really
don't like working in a 9-5 job
yes you get paid for the 40 hours of
time that you put in
and particularly in the data science
field that pay tends to be extremely
generous but what you give up for that
that is
your time is of insane magnitude
i think there's a lot of people who get
the idea of job security into their
heads
but as i think a lot of people figured
out this year during the pandemic
that is a complete and utter myth you'll
always be able to build an income
so long as you have skills that are
desired in the broader marketplace
but there are absolutely no guarantees
in the world with your job
something happens to it you get fired
you want to move
who the hell cares your job is not going
to last forever
to be fair that's true of youtube and
the income streams that it brings me as
well
but here's the key difference it's
scalable for a while
i've made it my goal to produce one
programming or stats tutorial per week
as well as one other type of video i
haven't always lived up to that
but that's at least been my objective
here's the thing
six months ago almost from today
actually
i hit 1 000 subscribers on this channel
now all of a sudden i'm reaching five
times as many people as i used to
roughly but to be honest i don't really
actually have to do
that much more work than when i was only
reaching 1 000 subscribers
and that to me is an absolutely
beautiful thing the key here is scale
yeah i guess theoretically i could work
two 40-hour per week jobs
then i'm doubling the impact that i have
on the world and
roughly i'm doubling the amount of money
that i have coming in
but who in their right mind wants to do
that i work to live
i do not live to work but what i do here
can be built upon
theoretically at some point in the
future i could have 500
000 subscribers on this channel so i'm
reaching 100 times as many people as i
am today
and i have roughly around 100 times the
amount of income coming in
all that with not that much extra work
and let's just say that if i 100
x to the current amount of income that i
have coming in from youtube
the current nine-to-five job that i work
would be optional at best
so yeah the passive income model
associated with youtube
is a wonderful thing and that's
absolutely key then you might think
okay i'm a data scientist but why make a
youtube channel all about that
well i'm going to approach that question
both from a personal perspective
and a market-based perspective and i'm
going to tie the latter
back to this broader conversation about
income first of all back when i was in
graduate school
i used to run lab sessions for a really
large intro stats class
so i would do a lecture for about 20
minutes then we would work on stats
problems together
come back at the end and go over the
answers that kind of thing
and i absolutely loved it i loved
getting the opportunity to inspire
people
maybe even to major in the field and of
about
30 plus instructors who were involved in
this program
i would consistently get either the
highest or close to the highest
student reviews of all of them so
to me it was a really amazing thing and
obviously it kind of got me thinking
now i have no interest whatsoever in
becoming either a professor
or like a high school teacher and also
i found that when i was teaching the
same class over and over again
that the magic of it kind of started to
wear off but i do
love education there's no question about
that it's just not something that i
currently do
or frankly want to do within the
confines of a nine to five job
so again this is why i love the youtube
model so much
it allows me to create content on
whatever it is that i want
and continue to progressively reach a
larger and larger audience
certainly a lot larger than i can reach
from within a classroom
i think the first question that anybody
has to ask if they're thinking about
making a youtube channel however
is do you actually have something to say
that is there's
tons of different channels out there on
this platform
now are you actually putting something
out there that's different from what's
already there
and my answer to that was and remains a
resounding yes
for example i think there's a
disproportionate amount of content out
there that's all about focusing on ml
now i say it again and again in my
videos i love
ml and i do videos on it but it's only a
small piece of the overall puzzle that
is data science
i think what a lot of people learning
data science really want
is some kind of structure to the madness
i make jokes about it all the time but
there's
way too much out there that a lot of
people feel expected to know
and i do completely reject outright the
notion that
every single job out there is different
no
there are some universal principles that
we can think about
that are going to apply to the vast
majority of people
more on that later but then i think
there's way too many people out there
who are proclaiming to be gurus
and to be quite honest there's almost no
such thing as a true data science guru
because the field is just too new and it
evolves too quickly
from day one when i launched this
channel i would try to be completely
straightforward with what i
am that's somebody with five that's now
six years of experience doing data
science
who happens to know some things and
when you work on actual jobs that's the
type of person that you're probably
going to learn the most from
for the most part it's not going to be
from some professorial or some
self-proclaimed guru type but i try to
be as straightforward as possible
and to conduct this channel with
integrity and associated with that
is the fact that i never have any plans
on this channel to create any sort of
course
there's so much information out there on
the web on data science
that most people are not going to have
to spend a penny in order to learn the
particular topic that they want to learn
granted there is value in courses in
terms of how they organize and structure
different content
but honestly that is so close to what i
already want to do with this channel
which is to provide some sort of
structure to people
that i really at least at this time see
absolutely no purpose in starting up a
course on this channel
and honestly i would feel like a total
sleazeball for doing it
to be totally fair of course i wouldn't
be doing this channel
just as charity work if it wasn't
bringing me in some kind of revenue
and yes i do collect revenue from this
channel through a combination of
ads patrons and amazon affiliate links
and yeah i know there's a lot of you out
there who don't like seeing the ads
but the way i see that that's a pretty
acceptable trade-off for having freely
available information that i'm not
asking you to pay for
so that's a perfect segue into what's
the plan for this channel in 2021
well to put it simply i do love the idea
of this channel being a one-stop shop
for you to learn data science
i've put together a study pathway for
prospective data scientists where i
stress that
first and foremost you should learn
statistics i make the case that
every data professional out there pretty
much should learn sql
and then data scientists should pick one
of r or python
and then master it well over the course
of 2021
i'm going to build out a sql tutorial
series i'm going to finish my
series on statistics and art tutorials
and i'm going to continue to bring you
my perspectives on the latest and
greatest news and trends
that are happening in the data science
world something that i will say is that
i've received an increased number
of requests to not forget about data and
business analysts
to broaden my focus beyond just data
science
so to you guys out there i'm going to
try to start making some content
directed towards you as well
now one thing that i do with this
channel on occasion as well
is to talk about real life topics like
the election
the virus and the stock market and try
to bring some degree of data driven
perspective to those things
i do that because on one hand those
topics are extremely fun to talk about
but i do also think it's incredibly
educational to learn how to think of
these things
in the same way that you would a real
world data problem
again there's way too many videos out
there about how to create some magical
algorithm that's not actually magical to
predict something
meanwhile there's not enough videos out
there about
the underlying data how to question that
the assumptions behind whatever it is
you're doing
and at the end of the day in virtually
all real world business data problems
those sorts of things are where the
majority of your impact is going to come
from
so to be honest i don't have plans to
change around all that much with this
channel
except that i'm going to try to be as
consistent as possible
i'm going to complete out tutorial
series on sql
r and julia as well as continue to talk
about
general data related topics and the data
science industry
and hopefully when it's all said and
done this can be
one central location where you can go
and learn all the different facets of
data science
with that said i do make a concerted
effort to read the comments on my videos
and some of the best video ideas that
i've ever had
come from you guys so by all means
whenever you guys have ideas of things
you'd like me to cover
let me know and i will try to serve you
guys as best as i possibly can
the final thing i'll say in this video
is thank you to all 5
000 plus of you who've subscribed and
those of you who tune in
you've made this all both possible and
worthwhile
and frankly i'm just getting started the
goal is
50 000 by the end of next year thanks
again
and here's to 2021 and the new chapters
that it's going to bring in all of our
lives and in our data science journeys
so until next time richard on data